hey guys it is the 8th of July I am a
sick version of just McDonald and I
promise this is the last GameSpot news
episode of the week with PewDiePie in it
probably since we spent yesterday
talking about the famous YouTube let's
play as earnings it seemed only fair to
spend some time today shedding light on
PewDiePie's follow-up video where he
says money it doesn't make you happy
PewDiePie said in his video that money
is a topic he tries to avoid explaining
whenever it comes out how much I made a
certain year people just get so shocked
a lot of people were also very angry
they thought it was unfair they thought
I just sit on my ass and yell at the
screen over here which is true but
there's so much more to it than that
the youtuber adds that he's just as
happy as he was pretty millionaire if
you want to check out the full video you
can catch it in our story on gamespot
343 industries has made suggestions
today after what resolution we might be
playing Halo 5 at halo 5 guardians
campaign and multiplayer modes will be
running at 60 frames per second but it
seems we'll have to wait a while for a
locked-down number on the resolution 343
lead producer Chris Lee told gaming bolt
quote so we're still optimizing the game
as we haven't launched so we haven't
locked in our final resolution yet but
we will talk more about that in the
future the game's beta ran at 720p
although 343 indicated that 720 was not
going to be the final resolution Lee was
also asked if the Xbox ones esram issues
prevented the game from reaching a
higher res to which he replied it didn't
cause any issues for us in things that
are dividing gamers a hacker linked to
the lizard squad group that brought down
Xbox Live and PSN last Christmas has
skirted a prison sentence even though
the 17 year old Julius Z killed Kevin
Maki was convicted of more than 50
thousand charges related to cyber crimes
a Finnish Court has sentenced him to a
two-year suspended sentence
weirdly he's also been ordered to quote
fight against cyber crime in what I can
only hope is some kind of teenage
reformed Batman
two Asian he has not however been given
any kind of prison sentence the central
cyberattack in question occurred when
the lizard squad brought down Xbox Live
and PSN between Christmas Day and New
Year's forcing countless gamers to
actually spend time with their families
over the holiday period let me know down
in the comments if you reckon the
hackers should have received a harsher
sentence or not and why you can head to
GameSpot where we've got news on
Microsoft layoffs and no man Sky's
trading and economy explained that is
everything I wanted to tell you about
today as always let me know what you
cared about and I'll catch you tomorrow